اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في ساعه اخباريه مفصله
من العربيه نبداها بالعناوين
معارك طاحنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
في الخرطوم واتهامات متبادله بخلق الفدن
المعلنه
[تصفيق]
وسط مخاوفها من تفاقم الوضع الانساني
الامم المتحده تاسف لاخفاقها في وقف الحرب
في السودان
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
السفر الروسي في واشنطن يعتقد ولايات
المتحده لتشكيكها في استهداف الكريمين
بالمسيرات
الجيش الاسرائيلي انسحب من داخل البلده
القديمه من نابلس بعد مقتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تغطيهنا المستمره
للقتال في السودان بين قوات الجنرين
البرهان وحميتي الاتهامات والاتهامات
المضاده بخلق الهدن بين طرفي النزاع
تتواصل الجيش السوداني يعلن تدمير عربات
قتاليه للدعم السريع في الساعه الاولى من
الصباح واحباط محاوله للتعزيز قوته في
محيط القص الجمهوري في المقابر يتهم الجيش
بل يتهم الجيش بمهاجمه قواته واحياء
واحياء سكنيه اما الوضع الانساني بات
كارثيا
وترافقه تحذيرات دوريه من الاسوا الامم
المتحده على لسان امينها العام تاسف
لاخفاقها في وقف الحرب في السودان
واستمرار خارق الهدن
فكان المعساه يعني صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد
والاولاد يعني ما عندهم تاشيره وخليناهم
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت الادانات
من تحت الدرك وطلال من يعني
من الاجوبه التوتر والضرب
اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان قوات
الجيش بشان قصف عشوائي على عدد من مواقع
تمركز قواتها وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم
الهدنه الجديده التي بدا سريانها اليوم
مؤكده على ان القصف الذي شده الجيش
بالمدافع والطائرات يشكل تجاوزا سافرا
للاعراف والقوانين الدوليه ومن جهه اخرى
اكد جيش السوداني على ان قواته اشتبكت فجر
اليوم مع قوات الدعم السريع بعد ان حاولوا
الهجوم على قياده منطقه بحي العسكريه
واضاف جيش السوداني ان قواته دمرت عددا من
العربات القتاليه التابعه للدعم السريع
واستلمت خمسه عربات بل خمس عربات تم تركها
في ميدان المعركه مؤكدا ان قوات الدعم
السيئه تلقت عقابا حاسما
وتشتت قواتها ما بين قتيل وجريح وهارب
اظهرت الصور اقمار صناعيه حريقا في حظيره
الطائرات في مطار خرطوم الدولي مختلفه
لمطايع خرطوم الدوري حيث اشتعل حريق واحد
من طائره متضرره واخر بالقرب من البوابه
الشماليه للمطار الذي شهد اشتباكات عنيفه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه
[موسيقى]
من مقر رسمي للرئيس ونوابه ومن مضافه
للرؤساء الاجانب تحول القصر الجمهوري
الجديد بالسودان الى بؤره رئيسيه للسياحه
فالقصر الجمهوري بات اكثر نقاط اشتعالا
الى جانب محيط القياده العامه للجيش ومطار
الخرطوم القصر مقره العاصمه الخرطوم
ويتكون من ثلاثه طوابق من يسيطر فعليا
عليه واين تدور الاشتباكات هذا هو القصر
هناك يتجاذب طرف الصراع السيطره على الاقل
اعلاميا قوه الدعم السريع اعلن السيطرتها
على القصر قبل اسبوعين لكن الجيش خرج
مرارا لينفي ما وصفه بالمعلومات المضلله
والكاذبه غير ان قوات الدعم السريع نشرت
فيديو لعناصرها من داخل القصر مؤكده بسطه
سيطرتها عليه
ومؤكده كذلك احتفاظها بمواقع استراتيجيه
اخرى بينها مطار الخرطوم حاليا الاشتباكات
لا تزال مندلعه بين الطرفين بمحيط هذا
القصر لكنها تخطت المواجهات بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني فالاخير
استخدم قوات الشرطه الاحتياطيه من كافه
الولايات وهي ما وصفتها قوات الدعم السريع
بالقوه المقاتله والمعاديه وفي وقت يحاول
فيه الجيش وقوات الاحتياط تقدم نحو القصر
تحت غطاء جوي تتصدق قوات دعم باسلحه رشاشه
وبمضادات الطيران
ومن خرطوم بحر مشاهدينا ينضم الى الصحافي
محمد اسحاق عثمان اهلا بك محمد وكيف هي
الاوضاع في بحر الان
صباح الخير احمد لا زالت هذه الوتيره في
التصاعد الاشتباكات اليوم دخلنا منذ ليله
الامس اخذت الاشتباكات والمعارك منحا
جديدا ربما ما زالت التكثيف هذه الطلعات
الجويه التي اشاهدها في هذه اللحظات
الطائرات تحلق في سباء الخرطوم بكثافه
المعركه بدات فجره اليوم كما ذكرتم قبل
قليل في منطقه البحر المركزيه
قبل قليل ايضا كانت هناك معركه شرسه مع
سلاح الاشاره في منطقه موقف شند القديم
كما
استهدافها كذلك من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
ودائره معركه
[موسيقى]
ايضا تزداد فيه شراسه المعارك في هذه
اللحظات ربما الجيش يتحدث عن احكام
السيد فصل الجمهوري
تمام الدعم السريع تتحدث عن سيطرتها للقصر
ولكن الجيش يتحدث عن تطوير كامل وقطع
الامدادات التي كانت تاتي عن طريق البحر
كما علمنا او عن طريق النيل من قبل بحري
من منطقه فندق قصر الصداقه الذي تسيطر
عليه هذه القوات قوات الدعم السريع تستعمل
بعض القوارب عن طريقا مين للمد وايصال
المدد الى الموجودين داخل القصر الرئاسي
الان تم قطع هذه الامدادات طبعا علمنا
ايضا قبل قليل احمد بان منطقه ام درمان
تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه في هذه اللحظات
وتكثيف لنقول الجيش وربما هم يزحفون
باتجاه محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون ايضا هذه
المنطقه التي يسيطر عليها او تسيطر عليها
وتدعم السريع ايضا
هو قرار كما علمنا اتخذته القوات المسلحه
او الجيش
بانهاء هذه المعارك او اسراع السيطره
بصوره فعليه على جميع المواقع التي يسيطر
عليها الدعم السريع وهذا هو التفسير
المنطقي لهذه الكثافه للطيران الذي يحلق
في هذه اللحظات ويبدو انه يطور العاصمه
الخرطوم الطيران يحلق في هذه اللحظات هل
يكتفي فقط بالرصد والمتابعه ام هناك غارات
نفذت في هذه اللحظات واتحدث عن بحري
تحديدا محمد
نستمع الى جميع سماع المضادات الارضيه
وبعض الدولي
والانفجارات من الواضح بان هذا الاستهداف
بطبيعه الحال يستهدف مواقع واهداف مختلفه
في هذه اللحظه التي يحدثك الان الطيران
يحلق في منطقه شمال بحر يبدو بان الطيران
يساند المشاه في هذه اللحظات في هذه
العمليه التي اطلق عليها الجيش بانها
ستكون كاسحه في الساعات المقبله الجيش
ايضا يتحدث عن ان القوات الدعم تتركز
امدادتها القادمه من خارج ولايه الخرطوم
من جهه الغرب وخاصه في منطقه ام درمان
ماذا عن بحري هل هناك ايضا امدادات تاتي
من خارج الولايه عن طريق هذه المنطقه
منطقه الخرطوم البحري
نعم كانت الامدادات تاتي بطبيعه الحال من
منطقه شرق النيل وتاتي من خلال الارتباط
ما بين بحري وشرق النيل الطريق مفتوح كما
كما تعلم ولكن يتحدث الجيش الان بان هذه
الطائرات ايضا قلت بانها
تحلق فوق
المناطق الحدوديه لولايه الخرطوم في
لاي دعم لقضاء الامدادات الداخله سواء
كانت من الشمال او من الغرب او من
الاتجاهات المختلفه لانبات هذه القوات
وقطعها من عمليه الامداد تماما لذلك الجيش
يتحدث بان هذه الطلعات الجويه تعمل الان
على مراقبه حدود ولايه الخرطوم ومداخلها
الاوضاع الانسانيه كيف تبدو محمد واحنا
نتحدث هذه المواجهات في منطقه بحري ايضا
الان في منطقه شمال بحري فيما يلي المناطق
او الاحياء المجاوره لامتداد يسرى
الحلفايه تبدو الحياه هنا طبيعيه جدا
الناس الاحظهم في يخرجون
لقضاء حاجياته بصوره طبيعيه الاسواق هنا
تعمل البحال تعمل صحيح بانها ليست بالوضع
الطبيعي الكامل ولكن اكثر تحسلا من الايام
الماضيه الان الحركه هنا تبدو طبيعيه الى
حد
ايضا شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه في اليوميه
الماضيين هل تبدو اليوم افضل حالا
نعم تتحدث المصادر بان اليوم ربما تبدو
هادئه حتى هذه اللحظات بعد عمليه
المطاردات التي تمت للقوات في هذه المنطقه
ولكن الملاحظ احمد بان الجيش هذه المره
ربما ركز طبيعه عملياته في محيط القصر
الجمهوري وبمنطقه مطار القرطوم
لهذه لاهميه هذه المناطق التي نتحدث عنها
كما تعلم انتشار قوات الشرطه في الايام
الماضيه وخاصه قوات الاحتياطي المركزي هل
احدثت فارقا كبيرا على الصعيد الامني محمد
هذه القوات هذه القوات الاحتياطي المركزي
تمركزت في جنوب الخرطوم بصوره واضحه وكان
لها اثر كبير جدا في استرداد عدد من
المسروقات والسيطره وتقليل عمليات السلب
والنعم ولكن هذه القوات لا تشكل وجودنا
الان في شمال الخرطوم منطقه الخرطوم بحري
وجسر الحلفايه وهذه المناطق لا توجد يوجد
الجيش وبعض الاستكازات لا زالت موجوده من
قبل قوات الدعم الشرقيه التام للشرطه في
منطقه بحري يمكن ان نقول بحسب مشاهداتنا
تتواجد فيها قوات الاحتياط المركزي ايضا
ام لا
نعم علمنا بانه موجودون في بعض الاحياء
ولكن الان ربما بعد هذه المعارف وبعد ان
دفع بقوات الاحتياط المركزي مسانده لهذه
العمليات الحربيه وما دار امس بمنطقه
السوق العربي في وسط الخرطوم ظلت هذه
القوات ربما ايضا هي مسانده للجيش وتنشغل
الان بهذه العمليات الحربيه اسنادا للجيش
مامد الدمار الذي طال السوق العربي من
السوق العربي بسبب هذه الاشتباكات بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش من جهه وايضا
اضافه كما تفضلت يعني رفقه الجيش كانت
هناك وتعطي مركز مشاركه ايضا للجيش في هذه
العمليات
نعم علمنا من بعض المصادر احمد بان منطقه
وسط الخرطوم ربما قد تكون شهدت ضبارا
كاملا بالامس من خلال هذا يعني التبادل
الكثيف للاطلاق النار وهذا الدوي وهذه
الانفجارات التي هزت الخرطوم باكملها ليله
امس مما جعل وسط الخرطوم
يبدو وكانه مدينه اشباح
طيب ماذا عن موضوع النزوح محمد يعني هل
هناك حاله نزوح كبيره رصدتني منطقه بحري
الى ولايه اخرى في السودان وما تكون اكثر
امنا
نعم لعل المنطقه التي ذكرتها قبل قليل
منطقه جسر الحلفايه لانها تبدو اكثر توازن
واملا خلال هذه الايام الاخيره لذلك تجد
الكثيرين ياتون من مناطق مختلفه من مدن
الخرطوم
المدينه وشرق النيل ياتون الى هذه المنطقه
لانها تبدو اكثر هدوءا وامانا وتتركز فيها
الحافلات التي تقابل سواء كان الى
الولايات المختلفه ولايات السودان
المختلفه الاحظ في هذه اللحظات من المنطقه
التي انا فيها تواجد كبير جدا لهذه
الحافلات
ترفع ج
سر الحلال الذين يودون مغادره الخرطوم الى
ولاياتهم بل اكثر من ذلك هناك حافلات تنقل
الناس لا زالت الى جمهوريه مصر الشقيقه عب
ر ما بين البلدين المواد التموينيه من
اغذيه وايضا بالنسبه للادويه يعني كيف
يمكن وصفه وضعها وحالها في
في الخط في خط بحري تحديدا
في هذه المنطقه وكنت قد قمت بجوله عصر
الامس لعدد من الصيدليات تفتقر بطبيعه
الحال بعض الادويه لاصحاب الامراض المزمنه
من الضغط والسكري وما شعبها تفتقد بوجود
هذه الادويه الا ما ندر
قمت بجوله في عدد من الصيدليات حتى ان
وجدت تجد الاسعار بطبيعه الحال صفاء الفرد
كبير الناس يعانون هنا بالنسبه للمواد
الغذائيه الاخرى ارتفاع جنوني في الاسعار
ربما اصبحت ضعفا بالتحديد في الاشياء التي
هي في المتداوله اليومي من الخبز وما
شابهها من الاغراض التي يتناولها المواطن
شكرا لكم معنا الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان
وسنكون معك في متابعه دائما لتطورت
الاوضاع هناك
المواقع التي يتحدث عنها الجيش قبل قليل
في بيانه الذي صدر قبل دقائق ويفيد بان
هناك اشتباكات انطلاق منذ صباح اليوم نحن
استمعنا الى هذه الاصوات بوضوح هذه
الاصوات كانت الاعنف والاقوى من حيث
القوه التفجيريه للقذايف التي استخدمت
وانطلقت من الطيران الحربي بكثافه شديده
من
بحر حله حمد حي الاملاك هذه هي المناطق
التي تظهر منها اعمده الدخان
وهي ايضا في منطقه تظهر ايضا ربما مواقع
في محيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاحياء الغربيه ربما منها هذه الاصوات
تستمعنا لي بقوه شديده قوتها وتاثيرها كان
عاليا جدا الابواب والنوافذ كانت تهتز في
مواقع بعيده عن هذه المنطقه انا شخصيا
احسست بذلك
ايضا ورده تقارير من مواقع مختلفه الاهالي
استمعوا الى هذه الاصوات ومنهم ان استيقظ
يعني في حاله من حالات
الرعب جراء هذه الاصوات القويه لكن هذه
اذا
المواقع التي تم استهدافها وبيان المسلحه
اكد ذلك بطبيعه الحال كانت هناك حصيله من
الخسائر رصدتها القوات المسلحه تمثلت في
الاستيلاء على عدد من العربات الخاصه
بقوات الدعم السريع والعربات مجهزه
بالاسلحه والمدافع الرشاشه ومدافع
الكاتيوشا ايضا
بحسب البيان ايضا فان الحصر ما زال جاريا
سعر هذه المعركه هناك معلومات تفيد بان
هناك قاده من قاده الدعم السريع موجودون
في ذلك الموقع
وربما يعني
مهاجمتهم بسلاح الجو في هذا الصباح
يعني اطلاقا او الطلعات الجويه التي كانت
بالامس كانت قصيره المدى متباعده
التوقيتات ايضا لكن اليوم شهدنا قصفا
متواصلا لاكثر من تقريبا حوالي ساعتين
متواصلتين قسم مكثف ومركز من هذه المنطقه
جمال
القصر الجمهوري من الناحيه الاخرى وهناك
ايضا اصوات صادره من محيط القصر الجمهوري
ومن محيط القياده العامه كما اسلفت لا
نعرف بعد حجم الحصيله النهائيه لهذه
الجوله من المعركه وصفها كذلك ولكن سنتابع
بطبيعه الحال عبر مصادرنا في تلك المنطقه
او عبر التواصل مع بعض الزملاء هناك
لمعرفه تفاصيل اوفى
عن المنطقه الاصوات اصوات الاطلاقات
وكذلك اصوات
طيران الاستطلاع نستمع اليه كل تقريبا ربع
ساعه
محمد هذه المعطيات ان قيادات قياده الصف
الاول في دعم ما زالت فعلا متواجده داخل
خرطوم وهناك ملحقات لها من قوات الجيش
وهذا ربما ما اكده محمد حمدان ايضا دقائق
وتدعمته الاعلاميه المختلفه عندما اتحدث
عن انه متواجد داخل الخرطوم ويدير المعارك
بنفسه
تماما هذه اذا اذا ما جمعنا هذه المعلومات
مع بعضها
وسير هذه
المعاركتها في بعض المواقع هذا كله يؤكد
انا بعض هؤلاء القادم موجودون في هذا او
داخل مدينه الخرطوم غير معلوم على وجه
الدقه اينعم ولكن
يعزز من هذه الفرضيات
وحتى يعني شوهدت لقطات
محمد حمدان قبل وهو في اقرب نقطه ربما من
القصر الجمهوري في احدى اللقطات التي تم
تصويرها عبر الموبايل بطبيعه الحال من
الصعب المؤكد مره اخرى من الصعب الحصول
على
المعلومات الدقيقه كل الزملاء الصحفيين
يحاولون ان يوصلوا الاخبار ويتحقق من
الدقه المعلومات عبر مصادر الخاصه على
الارض في بعض المواقع عبر شهود العيان هذه
يعني مهمه شاقه جدا هذه ربما الحرب
الوحيده التي يغطيها الصحفيون من مواقع او
بامكانيات متاحه حسب ما يتيسر لهم لخطوره
الامر تماما ليست هناك من معينات ونحن
يعني في في
بمناسبه اليوم العالمي لحريه الصحه ونتحدث
عن هذا الامر هناك معاناه كبيره جدا
للصحفيين في السودان ليست هناك من معاينات
لحمايه الصحفيين الخوذ الدروع المخصصه
لتغطيه هذه النوعيه من
غير متوفره لاي من الصحفيين ولذلك فهم
يقومون بمهمتهم بطريقه يعني
غريبه وايضا شاقه وتصعب من مهمه التاكد
والتحقق من هذه الاخبار وبطبيعه الحال
تحيه لكل الزملاء في هذا البلد الذين
يقومون بهذه المشاقه
بالتذكير الساده المشاهدين بانه نتابع
ايضا هذه الصور الجويه والحصريه لقناه
العربيه والتي تظهر مواقع تمركزات للدعم
السريع في منطقه بحري في حي حله حمد مقابل
القصر الجمهوري وكما ذكرنا مشاهدين يعتقد
ان هذه المنطقه هي تمركزات لقيادات الدعم
السريع شكرا لك من الخرطوم على الكاتب
الصحفي محمد شمس الدين تحياتي
سياسي المشاهدين اعراب الامين العام
المتحده عن اسفه لاخفاق المنظمه في وقف
الحرب في السودان حيث تقوض المعارك
المستمره جهود ترسيخ الهدنه وقال غوتيريشن
الامم المتحده فوجئت بتفجر العنف في
السودان ولم تتوقع تطور الاحداث بهذه
السرعه وشدد غوتيريش على ضروره التحرك
بصفه مستعجله ووقف كافه اشكال التصعيد
وايجاد حل يعيد السودان الى بر الامان
والسعي الى تحقيق الاستقرار والوحده
وكان وكيل الامين العام الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه قد عبر عن امله في عقد
اجتماع مباشر مع اطراف الصراع في السودان
في غضون يومين او ثلاثه انه يريد ان يوقع
طرف صراع في السودان على مواثيق تكفر
المرور الامنه للمساعدات الانسانيه
قبل ذلك اكد رئيس
الامم المتحده ان بلاده على استعداد
لاستضافه محادثات السلام بين طرفي الحرب
في السودان الرئيس الكيني وعلى حسابه في
تويتر قال ان بلاده تدرك اهميه مساهمه
الامم المتحده الحاسمه في بناء السلام ولا
سيما في القرن الافريقي مؤكدا من جديد
استعداد كينيا الاستضافه موحدات سلام
سودانيه من اجل استيراد والاستقرار
والنجاح في المنطقه
الحرب تابى ان تضع اوزارها في السودان
اصوات الرصاص والمدافع ترتفع على الاصوات
التي تنادي بالسلام والحوار الهدى المعلنه
ليست سوى مجرد كلام لا وقف الاطلاق النار
تحقق حتى الان ست هدى خرقت كل طرف يلقي
باللائمه على الاخر الجيش السوداني اصدر
بيانا رمى من خلاله الكره الى ملعب قوات
الدعم السريع متهما اياها بخرق الهدنه
ومواصله القصف العشوائي لبعض المواقع بما
فيها الاحياء السكنيه الموقف العملياتي
مستقر في جميع انحاء البلاد باستثناء
اشتباكات متقطعه مع الدعم في اجزاء من
العاصمه نتيجه لخروقها المستمره للهدنه
المعلنه
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اعاد الكره الى ملعب
الجيش مشيرا الى ان الدعم السريع لا ترفض
الهدى بل وتقدر جميع مبادرات الحل وما
زلنا نحن اليوم نعيش
والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويقصف مواقعنا
الطرفان يشيران ايضا الى بسط السيطره على
المناطق الحيويه خاصه في العاصمه الخرطوم
مبعوث رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني اكد ان
الوضع الامني تحت سيطره الجيش باستثناء
بعض الجيوب مشيرا الى ان هناك سبع عشره
ولايه سودانيه من اصل ثماني عشره تحت
سيطره القوات المسلحه حاليا اما قوه الدعم
فقد اعلنت انها تبسط سيطرتها على 99% من
ولايه الخرطوم وتعد بما سمته النصر القريب
الجيش عاد ليتهم الدعم السريع بارتكاب
عمليات نهب وسرقه في الخرطوم مستشار
حميدتين نفل اتهام واصفا ذلك بغير الصحيح
مسلسل الاتهامات والاتهامات المضاده مستمر
في ظل تواصل الاشتباكات الضاريه بدون افق
لنهايه الازمه حتى الان بلال البجدين
العربيه
شددت قوى الحريه والتغيير على اهميه
الوصول لوقف عاجل ودائم لاطلاق النار بما
يمهد لحل سياسي في البلاد واشادت قوى
الحريه والتغيير في الوقت ذاته بالموادره
الامريكيه السعوديه الداعيه الى السلام
الناطق باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير قال انه
بات من اللازم صنع قوات مسلحه
ومهنيه واحده وحكم مدني في السودان
هذا وبحث وزير خارج السعوديه الامير فيصل
بفرحان هاتفيا مع الامين العام لجامعه
الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط وقف التصعيد
العسكري في السودان وتناول الاتصال ايضا
مناقشه توفير الحمايه اللازمه هي المدنيين
السودانيين والمقيمين على ارضها بما يضمن
امن واستقرار السوداني وشعبه
في الوضع الصحي الذي يوشك على الانهيار
وفقا لتقديرات دوليه كشف الناطق باسم
اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان
سيد محمد عبد الله عن توقف اكثر من 67% من
المستشفيات المتاخمه لمناطق الاشتباكات عن
الخدمه مشددا على ضروره اعاده تشغيل هذه
المستشفيات وايقاف الاشتباكات في اقرب وقت
ممكن
ان هناك اكثر من 67% من المستشفيات في
مناطق النزاع متوقفه تماما عن الخدمه 89
من 88 مستشفى
يعمل منها فقط 29 بشكل بعدها بشكل جزئي
نحن نحرص على حياه الانسان نحاول مع لجان
المقاومه مع المتطوعين ومع الزملائنا ان
نعيد التشغيل هذه المستشفيات ولكن
القتال المستمر والقصف العشوائي وكل هذه
الاشياء تمنع ذلك للاسف
الكادر محدود لعدم تمكنوا من الحركه
الكادر الطبي لا يستطيع المعينات الطبيه
في تناقص مستمر وحتى الكهرباء والمياه
الاف الفارينه من الحرب السودانيه دخلوا
الى دوله جنوب السودان عبر معبر جوده وضع
انساني كارثي ومناشدات للمنظمات الانسانيه
لتقديم الدعم والمسانده على المعبر كاميرا
العربيه قابلت الفارينه من السودان الى
دوله جنوب السودان التي ينتمي اليها
اغلبهم
اكثر من عشرين الف شخص هي جمله عدد
الفارين من الاشتباكات التي شهدها عدد من
المدن السودانيه خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
دخلوا الى جنوب السودان عبر معبر جود
الجنوبي غالبيتهم من جنوب السودان والباقي
من جنسيات مختلفه
نحن من يوم 17 حتى يوم 30
سجلنا اجمالي عدد
286 اسره
الالاف من الحاربين من اتون الحرب التي
شهدتها عددا من المدن السودانيه عبروا الى
جنوب السودان عبر معبر جوده الجنوبيه وهم
يعدون العده بالذهاب الى جوبا او غيرها من
المدن الاخرى ولكن تذكره القبور تقف في
وجه الكثيرين منهم
العربيه
معبر جوده الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات